g4u sank my battleship hey youtubers
it's Charlie this week on agents of
shield we learned a lot more about
Skye's backstory and what she's really
been doing since she's been with the
team and we learned a little bit more
about the big bad of this season I've
also got some special announcements to
make about the Captain America Winter
Soldier trailer that's gonna be coming
later this week and my Thor the dark
world review so let's do a super quick
recap in the episode then talk about
what it means so in this episode the a
story is actually tracking down this man
named Chan who has superpowers it's been
stolen by this mystery organization we
later end up finding out it's basically
a group trying to do extremis based
experiments to try and create another
super soldier it's actually the same
organization from that first episode
with J August Richards remember it's
called project centipede and they
basically TAS centipede serum but it's
really just modified extremists it turns
out they're after him because an aspect
of his power helps stabilize the serum
remember in Iron Man 3 and in the first
episode people kept exploding just
because extremis is so volatile so
essentially the big bad this season is a
super group that's trying to create an
army of super soldiers the B story was
actually kind of surprising it's
essentially Skye's betrayal to rising
tide it turns out rising tide is
basically on the other end of this and
is the reason this chan person got
stolen we need to talk about the big bad
but first let's talk about Skye's
backstory so now that we know she's
basically looking for her parents and
trying to find out who she is
there's a reason she only has that one
name Skye she doesn't have a last name
on the show it's just called Skye is
because she's from an orphanage she
doesn't who her parents are and she's
trying to track them down and it turns
out that there is information on her
that was redacted by shield so Agent
Coulson offers to help but he says you
might not like what you find
I feel like this is a giant flag for
supervillain parents that or super being
parents obviously I don't think that is
the case I think it's more likely that
it's a supervillain we can all make
guesses on who we think her parents are
at this point but based on her abilities
in the tech world honestly I think it's
more like an evil Tony Stark situation
and think about who the you know Tony
Stark villain analogues are in the
Marvel Universe and start there when you
start guessing this might be a little
bit obvious but I think that her parents
are actually gonna be tied to this
mystery organization that's behind
project centipede and she's gonna have
to choose between them or shield
obviously since we're probably gonna get
a season two and she's not gonna leave
the show it's probably gonna be shield
choosing but let me know what your
thoughts are let's talk about the big
bad though so honestly there's two
options right now at the top of my head
there's aim and then there's Hydra
personally because Hydra is kind of more
known for energy-based weapons and like
the tesseract technology from the first
Captain America film I don't think it's
them honestly I think aim is a much
better fit just because they were the
ones that were working on extremists in
the Iron Man 3 film now obviously
Killian died in that film but aim is a
huge organization so obviously there's
other supervillains that could step in
to fill that vacuum but I do think we
will learn officially who they are by
the end of this season I don't think
that's gonna drag into season too well
let's talk about favorite moments real
quick first off battleship totally
awesome I love tabletop gaming wouldn't
it be funny in the next episode of agent
Ward used Settlers of Catan to teach
Skye international politics and what
about this clairvoyant obviously they're
talking about a super-powered person
someone with legitimate superpowers let
me know who you think that is but based
on the sinister connotation and kind of
like the way that was lit in that final
scene it makes me think that this person
is super evil whoever they are so who is
a super villain in the Marvel Universe
and is clairvoyant and I kind of laughed
a little bit when Cham lost that at the
end of the episode before he went
nuclear I don't think I've seen anyone
in Iron Man 3 or on this show who's
taken that serum and not gone bonkers
and I will say I heard one of the best
Agent Coulson lines ever in this episode
great they gave him a name that
basically tells you that once you give
someone a name they turn into an
so whatever you do if you think
someone's on the fence don't give them a
name they will turn into a total
overall I give the episode of B we
finally saw some super-powered people on
the show and we got a little more
information about the Big Bad this
season and move the overarching story
forward in a meaningful way which I
didn't feel like some of the previous
episodes have done it's nice to have one
off episodes every once in a while they
have some nice beats but you really want
this story to move forward you want to
find out who's behind this and you want
to find out what the big conflict is
going to be and how they're going to
resolve it in the teaser for the next
episode we actually see people suspended
in midair dead so I have a feeling that
either they're teasing the return of
graviton or it's going to be some sort
of other magnetic based thing if there's
anything you saw in the episode that you
thought was really important that I
didn't mention in the video be sure to
write it in the comments and we'll
discuss the fie I'll be posting my
supernatural video tomorrow morning be
sure to subscribe to get that Wednesday
has a new episode of arrow in American
Horror Story coven and since it's
Halloween week I'm doing a special Game
of Thrones video on Friday for that
thank you so much for watching as always
if you want to help me
please like and share this video in the
meantime you can click here to watch all
my other agents of shield videos and you
can click here to watch all my other
arrow season 2 videos thank you so much
for watching high five see you guys
tomorrow